The United States continues to make progress...
...in its denuclearization talks with North Korea...
...but will keep sanctions on the Asian nation,...
...White House Press Secretary Sarah Sanders...
...told a reporter after US President Donald Trump...
...met with a North Korean envoy.
In Turkey, U.S. Republican Senator Lindsey Graham...
...met Turkish President Tayyip Erdogan and Foreign Minister Mevlut Cavusoglu in Ankara...
...with the latest developments in Syria high on the agenda.
In Switzerland, the U.N. human rights office....
...called on Zimbabwe's government to "stop the crackdown against protesters"...
...and "excessive use of force" by security forces including firing live ammunition.
In Colombia, the Colombian government blames leftist ELN rebels...
...for the car bomb that killed 21 people...
...at a Bogota police cadet training academy.
Finally, the first members of a new caravan of Central American migrants...
...trying to reach the United States...
...started walking across southern Mexico.